[MUSIC PLAYING]
(SINGING) I've never been
the girl who gets attention.
I've never been the
one who got the part.
Believe me, there's no
honor in honorable mention.
But I've made it in art.
I've never been the type
to take the spotlight.
Some girls just
seem to know how.
Me, I've got a knack
for hiding in the back.
But maybe it's my turn now.
Once I lay around in languish, I
had a wicked case of the blahs.
All those days in
agony I anguished,
they got put on pause when
I heard that applause.
I've never been the type
to take the spotlight.
Some girls just
seem to know how.
But maybe tonight, if
the timing is right,
maybe these frightened feet
will sneak into the light.
Yes, there's no more maybe
because baby, it's my turn now.
I've never been the type
to take the spotlight.
Some girls just
seem to know how.
But maybe tonight, if
the timing is right,
maybe these frightened feet
will sneak into the light.
Yes, there's no more maybe
because baby, it's my turn now.
[APPLAUSE]